So when we're talking about rendering, we're talking about how do we see things inside
of Unreal Engine.
We have multiple buffer views as a visualization inside of Unreal.
So in the middle, you can see the main interface screen that you would generally see for most
of your projects.
However, we can separate these buffers from base color to specular.
We can even check normals, world tangent, opacity.
There's many different views that we can see at real time inside of Unreal Engine, which
you can select from inside the editor.
When we talk about lighting, we can have different lighting shapes.
We can have point lights and spotlights and skylights.
There's a whole different range of lights that you can use to get your real time effects
looking exactly how you want them.
We can change the type of light from static to stationary to mobile or dynamic, which
means you either bake the lighting or maybe it's partly dynamic or maybe it's fully dynamic.
We have features inside the engine such as lumens, global illumination and reflections,
which is Unreal Engine 5's real time lighting.
We have ray tracing built in that you can use for your projects.
And also we can select between forward and deferred rendering methods depending on what
you would like to use there.
So you can update the global illumination directly from the project to use the lumen
illumination.
And you can set a whole different bunch of properties here.
When you're digging into the projects and the content yourself, you can select between
the different rendering methods you would like to use there.
When we refer to textures, we're talking about images that hold visual data.
Textures inside of Unreal Engine have RGB and A channels, so the red, green, blue and
alpha channels.
And you can make tweaks to each of the textures on the right hand side details panel here.
You'll notice the details panel becoming a common theme throughout the use of Unreal
Engine's editing through the tools and the systems that we're using.
Details panel is always your go-to of where to edit this content.
So you do have adjustments that you can make with inside the textures of Unreal Engine.
When it comes to materials, we can create materials directly inside the editor.
We can create instructions for how you want that material to be rendered.
We can have material layers.
We can also create dynamic materials that can be affected at runtime, depending on your
desired outcome.
So we can change the shading models and the blend modes and different properties of materials
all directly inside of Unreal Engine and again through the details panel.
We also have meshes inside of Unreal Engine.
So NaNi is Unreal Engine 5's new virtualized geometry system.
So you can have millions of polygons being rendered on the screen at the same time to
a very high fidelity.
And we also have a static mesh editor built in, which you can use to edit the content
before it goes into your scenes.
To import meshes, you can go to the content browser and you can just go to add and import
or you can drag and drop the content in.
So if we just hop over to our editor again, you'll see there's content already here.
And because we clicked start a content and we'll go to the props folder.
So we've got some static meshes here.
So we have, imagine you had imported these static meshes.
This is where they would be.
So you can drag and drop your FBXs into the empty space here and that will import them.
You can click the import button and add files directly to your projects from there.
We also have a particle system called Niagara, which is Unreal Engine's new particle system.
You may see reference to Cascades sometimes and that's Unreal Engine's deprecated particle
system.
So you want to be using Niagara for all your particles moving forward.
And essentially this is an emitter's, a module's tool that you can use to create
the desired functionality.
You can animate the particles in there.
You can add scripts in.
Again, it's all very modular based to get the desired outcome that you would like there.
We can also support virtual productions.
So we have cinematic cameras built inside of Unreal Engine.
You can use composition to maybe have green screen performances composed in real time
inside of Unreal Engine.
So you can see everything updating based on the current frame inside of Unreal Engine
rather than waiting for it to render out.
We can do motion facial capture, sequence editing, and again, sequence being the cinematic
editing tool, and the in-camera VFX is also supported.
So more rendering features to maybe look into through the documentation.
The post-processing.
You can create film effects directly through the post-processing.
So whether that be lens flare or any other type of effects you'd like to add to your
scenes, you can do that through the post-process chain.
We have real time reflections supported, height and atmospheric fog, sky atmosphere.
So you can change the time of day, add clouds, the sun position, and this all gets added
under the hood inside the engine so that you can very quickly get different atmospherics
for your scene.
And then we have light mass tools which are the baking tools inside of Unreal Engine.